[Music]
every look at it in a certain light
Latin America is a kind of ideological
pendulum bridging opposite poles from
the military dictatorships of the 70s
and 80s the transition to democracy the
flood of an economic liberalization of
the 90s to the all-powerful statism of
the so-called socialism of the 21st
century you can almost say that in Latin
America everything is either black or
white the assault in Brazilia in early
2023 by the bolsonaro supporters on
Congress the Supreme Court and the
palatal palace which is the seat of the
presidency which is the latest example
of this kind of passionate Fury that is
so often difficult to make compatible
with democracy a fury what's more that
is always always dominated by certain
common parameters that I think we all
know perfectly well what if in some way
and despite recent events this pendulum
is really beginning to swing could Latin
America be at an ideological Turning
Point let's find out
[Music]
the first 10 years of the 21st century
saw practically the entire region
plunging into what various political
analysts called the red tide in March
2005 for example it was estimated that
75 of Latin America's 350 million
inhabitants were governed by leftist
parties at that time we can remember
Hugo Chavez Daniel Ortega Lula de Silva
Rafael correra Evo Morales and the
Kitchener family making many reforms
both economic and social to get closer
to socialism and to nourish the state
with more and more interventionist tools
and keep in mind I'm not only talking
about the economic field what happened
in Caracas and manangua where you know
all too well went far beyond the Public
Accounts
foreign
not to mention the assault on Democracy
itself
in that Maelstrom of socialist
enthusiasm multilateral platforms were
generated such as the union of the South
American nations unisur the community of
Latin America and the Caribbean States
selak and the boulevard Alliance for the
peoples of our America Alba come on the
process seems to be unstoppable but
let's pause a moment because with
corruption and the popular vote in those
places where it was respected of course
the waves of these immense red Tides
began to break one by one look at this
McCree wins in Argentina and puts an end
to kirshnerism after 12 years Venezuelan
opposition wins largest number of seats
and will control the National Assembly
impeachment Dilma Rousseff is impeached
as president of Brazil Lenin Moreno
blocks Rafael Correa Ecuador votes in
referendum in favor of limiting
presidential terms to two terms
bolsonaro is elected president of Brazil
as you can see the tournament the region
is taking since 2015 generated a
scenario totally contrary to the red
tide whose forces were greatly weakened
although not defeated the victory of
Lopez obrador in Mexico followed by the
defeat of Mauricio macri in 2019 along
with the social uprisings in Chile and
the return of evil Morales party to
power in Bolivia in 2020 kicked the
Latin American political chessboard once
again but was the secession of events
really a remake of the red tight well
let's take a look
[Music]
of political change
in July 2018 when 53.19 of Mexicans
delivered Andres Manuel Lopez obrador
amlo to the presidency it not only broke
the dominance of the PRI the
institutional revolutionary party which
had only briefly eroded by the pan the
National Action Party in the country but
it also gave the first standings of the
coming change although amlo had to exist
as a lone wolf for a while accompanied
by dissident presidents of socialism
such as Pinera in Chile bolsonaro and
Brazil UK and Colombia and macri in
Argentina the social outbursts in Chile
and Ecuador in 2019 would end up opening
a real Pandora's Box in the region
Empire
the wave of riots in Santiago which
ended up even provoking the start of a
process to change the Constitution was
possibly a tremendously traumatic shock
for the countries opposed to the red
tide up to that moment the Chilean model
has served an example of stability and
growth thanks to its more
market-oriented policies however
following the riots that idea that model
began to cease to be an objective and
became a myth with a high political cost
yes that was the result who would want
to replicate such a model
and you know what it was just then when
from Caracas the melancholic custodians
of the so-called 21st century socialism
began to protect an ideological
hurricane that would once again
possession the left at the top of
political power
Supply
[Applause]
however the truth is that at this time
the story played out very differently at
least very different from what the
Maduros calebos and Company had in mind
those outbreaks of violence did not make
Society demand the return of the role
models and custodians of the red tide
but rather generated results somewhat
watered down support for neither one nor
the other listen up
her fading red
if we look at the trend of the most
prominent governments in Latin America
in 2019 we can see the left has been
decimated from the political map of the
region except for a few specific cases
such as Mexico Nicaragua Cuba and
Venezuela
however some three years later the
bolivaran breeze seems to have done its
job with changes as striking as those
that have taken place in the bastions of
Latin American Center rates such as
Colombia
if we take into account the map well it
seems quite clear we could say that the
red tide is back that the socialism of
the 21st century has taken power again
once again the bolivaran revolution is
setting the music to follow right well
the truth is actually that it's not
yes it is true the leftist parties
sometimes parties and movements closely
linked to the old bowl of Iron Guard
have once again taken power however wait
a minute because the truth is that the
profile of most of the current leaders
seems very far from what Chavez Castro
Ortega and Company would have argued for
back in their day you don't believe me
we'll take a look
declaration is Venezuelan
is
associated
Venezuela
Republic
foreign
again condemns the madurai regime in
Venezuela that is to say the region
turned to the left that is undeniable
[Music]
however the left seems somewhat
different from the one that played a
leading role at the beginning of the
century it doesn't seem far from that
revolutionary left that was in love with
Hugo Chavez's long speeches the new
governments embody something that kind
of diluted Latin American socialism
perhaps even a kind of Latin social
democracy and what can I say we may like
these political currents more or less
but I don't think there is much doubt
that they seem much better in all
aspects than the Revolutionary movements
of the beginning of the century
in general the new governments do not
talk about revolutions expropriations
nationalizations and the like and that
seems to be in advance because in the
long run it could generate much more
stability let me make it clear whether
you like your policies or you don't the
change of cards seems much less radical
even Lula has won the elections in
Brazil with an electoral ticket that has
Geraldo Alchemy as his running mate an
icon of the Brazilian center right and a
former electoral opponent of Lula
himself perhaps in some ways Pedro is
still partly The Only Exception he seems
to be too comfortable with tyrants like
Maduro but even in Colombia the
political reality under petrol is a far
cry from what most Latin American
leftist movements were during the early
21st century and the question is why
this Sudden Change is a generational
issue is the result of self-criticism of
the part of Latin American left is it
because they want to emulate European
countries maybe well maybe it's a little
bit of everything of course another
factor that may have contributed to the
loss of influence is perhaps Financial
Yes you heard me correctly check this
out
[Music]
no one can afford the party anymore
these visual party viewers the red Tate
at the beginning of the cycle had an
epicenter Caracas from the Venezuelan
Capital Hugo Chavez positioned himself
as a political but also a financial
model especially for all the adventurers
of the time take a look Evo Morales
joins Chavez anti-neo-liberal and
Anti-Imperialist project in his visit to
Venezuela one of the agreements signed
will be the 30 million U.S dollars that
Chavez has committed to deliver to
Bolivia for social Works besides
supplying all the fuel that Bolivia
consumes Venezuela enjoys its oil
Bonanza experts believe that President
Chavez has spent some 5 billion dollars
in energy Ventures outside Venezuela
including new or jointly operated oil
refineries in Cuba Uruguay and Brazil
Venezuela continues to hoard Argentine
dead Ecuador accepts donation of six
fighter jets from Venezuela the
Venezuela officializes crude oil supply
agreements Bolivia Haiti and Nicaragua
Venezuela officialized three direct
crude oil supply agreements for a total
of 1.48 million barrels per month to
believe Nicaragua and Heidi Under
special payment conditions that include
interest of two percent per annum you
see the credit card was making payments
here and there like there was no
tomorrow and of course it also financed
all kinds of very radicalized left-wing
political movements all of this helped
to bring together a Pulpit of
governments around that utopian project
of the great motherland or better the
great wallet
but if all this was happening officially
under the table it is estimated that
Chavez's assistance to its allies was
more complex the most emblematic case
would be that of Antonio Wilson who
admitted after being captured in Buenos
Aires to having taken about eight
hundred thousand dollars from pdvsa to
finance Christina kritzner's campaign in
2007.
Venezuela yes
and of course if the party was free why
not join in this is what many political
leaders in the first second and third
rows of the region may have thought now
they have changed their jackets besides
it is clear that those who took the
money and bought the drinks were the
most popular in the class today however
things are completely different
today Venezuela is practically bankrupt
with no possibility of economically
supporting any significant political
project the collapse of Public Accounts
as a result of the compulsive
nationalization of private Industries
and the lack of investment in oil
infrastructure has made Venezuela unable
to extract even its own oil and we're
talking about a country that has the
largest reserves of conventional crude
oil in the world this is a major field
we're talking about
and that was in 2019 because in 2022
they have barely managed to produce
around 700 000 barrels per day of course
when your coffers are full you can
indulge in all kinds of whims but when
they are empty that's another story but
let's move on
an increasingly limited left
if we go back to the political map of
2022 it is evident that the political
signposts have changed the players that
have come to power are somewhat
different or at least have changed with
respect to what was the norm in the
first decade of the 21st century now
they maintain more moderate rhetoric and
do not hesitate to raise the flag of the
Third Way which let me stress does not
mean that the political project is
attractive to us that will depend on
each individual case the defeat of the
referendum of the new constitution in
Chile the victory of Le Kelly pose
reforms the change of political leading
that seems to be approaching in
Argentina the new leaders of the left or
Center left are not only enjoying a
golden era but in many cases are losing
many of their major political battles
and that is despite having moderated
along the way and that is why we say
that historical pendulum of Latin
American politics may have broken of
course it may be that thinking of Latin
America as a left-right function may be
a bit old-fashioned in recent years the
region seems to have moved towards a
more populist anti-populis dynamic in
view of the failure of Christina
Fernandez evil Morales and Rafael
carrera's personalism
foreign
perhaps because of all this the wave is
no longer strictly red but a little
Pinker and in any case 2023 comes with a
very busy agenda for identifying what
will be the new political pendulum that
will set the pace in the region
Guillermo lasso will face a referendum
in February in which he will present the
main policies to the popular vote
seeking in the style of lackay Poe to
empower his management for the remainder
of the term Guatemala Paraguay and
Argentina will have to renew their
Executives while petrol will have its
first intellectual test as president in
October's Regional elections then the
fierce internal struggle of the ruling
party in Bolivia and the institutional
crisis in Peru raised questions about
the future of these nations while the
development of Lula's government in
Brazil will be key to understanding
where the Latin American left is heading
is it getting Pinker and Pinker will
they like this type of movement or not I
think the vast majority of us can agree
that it would be good news especially if
we take into account the history of this
region of course it's Latin America so
you never know but at this point it's
all over to you what do you think about
the pink wave currently affecting the
region do do you think that the 21st
century socialism project has already
been discarded or could it re-emerge is
the Latin American left renewing itself
or are they just keeping up appearances
leave us your comments below and let's
open a respectful debate of course have
you found this video interesting don't
forget to like And subscribe to all of
us here at visualpolitik thank you very
much once again for watching all the
best and I'll see you next time
[Music]